انطلق رحاله السعوديه في هذه اليحيى في
رحله على الدراجاته الهوائيه لدعم المنتخب
بلاده في رحله بدات من الرياض وتنتهي في
السفاره السعوديه في الدوحه ومن المتوقع
ان تستغرق رحلته تسعه ايام يقطع خلالها
800 كم
بمعدل يومي يصل ل 120 كيلو متر تقريبا
يذكر انه سبق للرحاله السعودي القيام
برحله سابقا انطلقت من العاصمه الرياض الى
موسكو خلال مونديال كاس العالم في روسيا
2018 في رحله استغرقت بضاعه اشهر
ومن منفذ سلوى الحدوديه ينضم الينا
الرحاله فهد اليحيى كابتن فهد مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
على القوه اولا
وقال لي اولا كم قطعت حتى هذه اللحظه في
هذه الرحله كما استغرقت حتى الان
الله يعطيك العافيه
الحدود ده بين السعوديه وقطر في المنفلوه
همم تقريبا لنا تسعه ايام انطلقنا من
الرياض من مكتب وزير الرياضه
مع الامير عبد
الامير همم
حلال احنا في الحدود مده الرحله تسعه ايام
قطعنا تقريبا يوميا 100 الى 120 كيلو
ممتازه وتقطعها فيه كم ساعه يوميا همم
يوميا من ثلاث الى اربع ساعات
100 100 كيلو من ثلاثه الى اربع ساعات طيب
طيب ممتاز انت همم طبعا المبيت وهمم ايضا
همم الفريق المساعد ايضا همم كمان معك همم
كابتن فهد همم كيف تعاملته مع الرحله حتى
هذه اللحظه واجهته صعوبات وغيره ايضا
كان معي ابطال هم سر نجاح هذه الرحله
ال- الاعلام المميز عبد الرحمن المطيري
والمهندس ابراهيم الرومي والاستاذ سلطان
السبيعي هذول هم ابطال الرحله وهم من
حققوا هذا النجاح المبهر ممتاز اا طيب انت
كل يوم تاخذ 30 الى اربع ساعات 100 كيلو و
تقريبا كنت تقدر تقطع ها المسافه في ساعه
او ساعه ونصف من الرياض الى الدوحه
بالطائره ليش اخترت انك تروح الى قطر على
الدراجه الهوائيه
هل هذا الحلم
عند سنوات كثيره وانا من سنوات
2018 في روسيا انا دائما احب اني ازر
منتخب بلادي الاخضر همم بطريقه خاصه على
درجه الهوائيه وان يعني اكون يعني نوصل
الرساله للعيبه الصقور والخبر ان الجماهير
السعوديه
معهم قلب باذن الله لتحقيق الانتصارات
والمراكز المتقدمه للمنتخب السعودي ايش
الاختلاف بين الرحله اللي انت كنت فيها
الى روسيا غير طبعا التوقيت مش الاختلاف
اللي لما استمر رحلتك الروسيه في مونديال
2018 واليوم في انك تذهب الى الدوحه لحضور
مونديال 2002 22
الفرق ان 2018 كانت المسافه طويله 5145
كيلو دفعتها في 75 يوم ولكن ما اخذ
التغطيه عليه 100 كبيره
الرحله هذه اقصر منها بكثير تقريبا 800
كيلو اخذ التغطيه اعلاميه كبيره جدا جدا
يعني تعدت الوطن العربي والشرق الاوسط
ممتاز ايش في موقف ما تنساه في مثل هذه
الرحلات سواء وانت رايح القطار او لما
ذهبت ايضا لروسيا موقف عالق في الدهن ما
يغيب
كنت في روسيا في منطقه اسمها كراسنا دار
قبل موسكم 500 كيلو وكنت يعني قريب من
تحقيق الحلم والوصول فااا كنت قاعد اناظر
الجوال على الخريطه
ورفعت راسي الى السيارات موقفه اني قدامي
ولا قدامي تريله دخلت التريله جاني ضربه
في الراس وفي الاسنان وتكسر السيكل
وقعدت يوم كامل كنت خايف اني ما استطيع
اني اواصل الرحله لكن الحمد لله
ما منعتك انك تكرر الرحله مره ثانيه وتكرر
هذه الخطوه
والقادم افضل وانا الان صبر لموافقه من
وزاره الرياضه والداخليه والخارجيه اني
اعمل اطول وحده في العالم لفه على الكره
الارضيه خمس قارات 84 دوله 70 الكيلو الى
خلال سنتين وشيرين راح نعطيها العام
القادم فهد انت تستخدم
الدراجه خلال الرحله كامله يعني ما تعتمد
على اي وسيله نقل الاخرى ابدا لا لا على
الدراجه ابدا كل
شيء عندنا الاستراحه هذا برنامج عالمي
يخلي كل الدراجين في العالم يراقبوا له
كتاب يتابعونك ويحفظ لك السيتي بعدين لما
تشوف وين رحتكم في المسافه كل شيء اشتراه
هذه
اليوم وغدا
اليوم بالليل ان شاء الله معزومين عند
اخواننا القطريين الله يعطيه العافيه ابن
سالمين قدم لنا كل الدعم الاعلامي
واستقباله الترحيب وبكره ان شاء الله
الصباح نكون في السفاره خادم الحرمين
الشريفين اللي نسلم التميمه ساعه السفير
اللي تم التوقيع عليها وانها الرحله بشكل
رسمي باذن الله